BE ONE A WEEK AGO OUR PRODUCERS
WHIPPED UP A MOCK TOURISM ADDED
FOR CHOP, ALSO KNOWN AS CHAZ,
THE NEWEST NATION IN THE WORLD.
YOU MAY REMEMBER IT.
>> THE CAPITOL HILL AUTONOMOUS
ZONE LOCATED WITHIN BEAUTIFUL
DOWNTOWN SEATTLE.
NOT WILD ABOUT COPS?
GOOD NEWS, BECAUSE THERE ARE
NONE.
MASKED MEN WITH GUNS WILL KEEP
YOU SAFE AND SOUND THROUGHOUT
YOUR STAY.
CHECK OUT THE STATE-OF-THE-ART
PORTA-POTTIES.
WE WILL SEE YOU SOON.
BE WELL AND I WANT TO APOLOGIZE
IF YOU FOUND WHAT YOU JUST SAW
HATEFUL, DISGUSTING, IF YOU WERE
TRAUMATIZED BY WATCHING IT,
TWITTER IS VERY CONCERNED YOU
MIGHT BE.
WE POSTED THAT FAKE OUT ON
TWITTER, TWITTER FLAGGED IT AS
"POTENTIALLY SENSITIVE CONTENT"
AND HIT IT FROM VIEW.
THEY WERE SAYING BEWARE, KEEP
YOUR KIDS FROM WATCHING THIS.
WHAT’S THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
WARNING PEOPLE OF THAT?
WE HAVE NO IDEA.
PROBABLY THIS EDITED VIDEO,
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW WHY,
MEANWHILE OUR HALF-HOUR RESPONSE
TO NATIONWIDE BLACK LIVES MATTER
RIOTS HAS A WARNING ON YOUTUBE.
"THE FOLLOWING CONTENT HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY THE YOUTUBE
COMMUNITY AS AN APPROPRIATE OR
OFFENSIVE TO SOME AUDIENCES."
BY OFFENSIVE THEY MEAN THAT THE
LEFT DOESN’T LIKE IT AND THAT IS
THE NEW STANDARD AND THERE’S
ONLY ONE RESPONSE UNDER THAT
STANDARD.
SILENCE THE PERSON WHO DISAGREES
WITH YOU.
THAT’S WHY CENSORSHIP IS NOW
EVERYWHERE, WHEN WHY THE TECH
COMPANY STARTED CENSORING THE
PRESIDENT, GETTING MORE
AGGRESSIVE AND SILENCING YOU.
YOU KNOW IT’S GOING TO HAPPEN,
IT WILL BE A RACE.
IT’S DIGITAL, WE WILL NEVER GET
IN, THE LEFT’S GOAL IS TO MAKE
THIS INVISIBLE AND THEREFORE
IRRELEVANT.
THE SAME TECH COMPANIES MAKE IT
VERY EASY FOR 12-YEAR-OLDS TO
WATCH HARD-CORE PORNOGRAPHY.
THEY HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THAT
AT ALL BUT POLITICAL VIEWS THEY